will weissman what's up
alan horey my friend thanks so much for
coming on the show dude
such a pleasure to be here we've been
talking about this for a while for a
while yeah glad we made it happen and
in l.a in elena i love it the show's
here
we have been talking about it for man
because well all everything that you've
been up to
with singularity university kitty hawk
ventures
a360 has been super super exciting to me
and attractive to aim to do my best to
get you on the program to unpack
these frontier technologies that we're
going to be talking about your
fascination with them your journey space
but it's perfect that it landed now
and even though we were trying to make
half for a while
great great to be here great to be with
you i'm super excited about the
opportunity to uh to get to chat with
you man
and there's a lot to the journey that
led us
to even having this fascination in
frontier
tech so let's unpack that who was will
growing up how did he become interested
in all of this
yeah so i uh originally grew up in
boston i was born in new york
moved up to the suburbs of boston from
like sixth grade
on and um it was always super
entrepreneurial
and really interested in technology i
was really lucky and had a supportive
uh family that hooked me up with some of
the early apple
products so i had like an apple tui and
was running a little computer bulletin
board
service and it was just always super i
think that was like eighth grade
uh landscaping business ice cream truck
business like just
loved creating my dad was an
entrepreneur so i was around that a lot
and at my core i'm i'm someone who loves
people and loves connecting with
with people and have been lucky enough
to be able to surround myself with some
pretty interesting individuals and then
love especially being around
entrepreneurs and the whole
entrepreneurial process and trying to
move the world forward through
entrepreneurship
so it's been an interesting journey like
like most people
uh not all up and to the right and uh
but it's been
you know it's been great it's really
been fascinating in uh the last
i don't know i've uh i came out to
california for college and then
grad school kind of most of my adult
life up in the bay area
uh most of that around technology
although took uh had about a
five-year stint as a restaurant uh
entrepreneur which was a
an amazing journey that i got to do with
three of my best friends and
created a company called world wraps
that actually uh invented and
popularized the wrap
so that was a pretty it was back in the
mid 90s and just like a
crazy crazy journey for me as a as a
younger guy like getting to go through
that and to do it with some of my
closest
uh closest friends was really cool and
then kind of started migrating into
venture and deeper technology and into
singularity university and bunch of
other stuff that we can get into
when when you're growing up and you're
seeing
that you're getting exposed to the
different
technologies as they're evolving did it
kind of come up the opportunity to
begin picking from different disciplines
because
you're you and i today really resonate
on how we're very
generalist we're very synthesis driven
and convergence focus
yeah i love that convergence is another
one did did you see
looking back like steve jobs said did
does it make sense like were you
connecting
dots from the different technologies at
younger ages as they were yeah no no so
i don't think i mean it's like shame on
me because like i was
uh one of my first i spent a couple
years coming out of college trying to
get into the venture capital business
they weren't hiring anyone out of
undergrad i ended up uh having this
opportunity
to join intuit when they were about a
hundred person company
and i was like the first person to work
on
internet stuff for them and so i
remember going to you know
yahoo.stanford.edu
i think was the url and like amazing
i left into it during that time to go
start a restaurant chain
you know as opposed to excuse me as
opposed to like jumping out and doing
one of the very first internet
uh companies so you know you look back
on this stuff and like what
you know the insights you should have
had uh and the actions you should have
taken but
like all these things i mean i find
myself in an interesting place now where
i'm able to take
all these very different experiences as
an entrepreneur as an investor as a
technologist as someone who's gotten to
focus on consumer facing businesses
as well and to kind of tie them all into
my
interactions with business my investing
my work around
abundance 360 and singularity and you
know creates a
allows you to be a very unique human
with a very unique perspective and
ultimately i think is you know serving
me serving me well now
not always the easiest of journeys and
uh but you know that's the way life
works and
and super grateful for uh to be at this
kind of intersection in this time and
and what i think is just an amazing time
in human history so
it does very much feel like we're at the
the godhead of the snake of the
auroboros and that we're
entering into the singularity which
we'll we'll talk about in some
of the metaphysics maybe later i'm
really interested in
as you're kind of doing you know you
move to california you're doing uh
ucsb and then stanford and then you're
doing the business school
you're kind of you know it was
interesting like you said you described
like the internet trend
and then like getting into food
i know it's so interesting but it served
a really important purpose and
also you gaining that skill set and
knowledge
from there but then you also have this
entry into venture capital entry into
investing entry into
uh operating and managing and making
sure that
uh a business is actually flower and
blossom
that's like a very fun sort of macro
level view
on just the way that things are trending
and
emerging and then how you can help fuel
fires
is that kind of how you know how you
sought and how did you get those first
sort of
steps in the door in that venture
capital space yeah yeah so i think
um agree with everything you said
one of the uh the things that has been
most helpful for me as an entrepreneur
or excuse me as an investor
is my journey as an entrepreneur um
and i took a bunch of swings at it it's
you know i have so much
empathy now for entrepreneurs and i
think uh you know i pay a lot of
attention now to the the
kind of mental well-being of my
entrepreneurs because
it's a the highest highs and the lowest
lows as well
and um you know it's a very there's a
very heavy weight
uh that one bears as an entrepreneur and
you don't always have people to be able
to talk to
and tremendous responsibility around
taking investors money and trying to
build something and
you know most of these early stage
startups don't don't work out and so
being able to
to help entrepreneurs kind of navigate
that
and give themself you know be kind to
themselves while still pushing them to
try to
you know make the impossible possible uh
i think is an important part of
of kind of my role as an investor and as
a
coach and mentor to some of these folks
for me i mean i had the opportunity to
be part of two
very interesting venture capital firms
at a business school
foundation capital i joined initially as
an entrepreneur and resident there and
then
worked with this amazing guy named bill
elmore who had founded the firm and
became a venture associate and just
loved that opportunity to kind of be
meeting with all these
entrepreneurs being able to discover all
these incredible different
technologies and business opportunities
then spent some time at a firm called
mavron which is a consumer tech focus
firm
started by howard schultz of starbucks
and dan levitan
and brought just such unique insight to
how consumers think and how to build
these consumer-facing businesses
i kind of then went to go take some
swings of being an entrepreneur again
uh before ultimately having this really
special opportunity to go join
singularity university about seven years
ago
and it was took me a little while after
joining su before i started kind of
realizing that this was you know such an
extraordinary ecosystem
part of what i was doing is building out
the curriculum for these large
programs that we were doing and so
whether it was around medicine or
finance or manufacturing or like the
global summit that you came to
or one of our international summits you
know i was thinking about
what are the most important kind of
topics technologies that that these
attendees should know about who are the
the you know people at the forefront um
uh the
the ceos the technologists that they
should get exposed to
and that naturally led to building up
this really interesting
network and getting invited into these
financings and starting initially to
write just very small
individual checks myself and then
putting together small syndicates and
as some of those companies started to
get some nice follow-on
investor traction and start to scale
larger syndicates and then that led to
some of those investors in the
syndicates being kind enough to anchor
me
in a in a fund and so i raised my first
venture fund at the end of 2018 kind of
a part-time thing while i was still at
uh
at su and then that's led to i left su
earlier in the year i'm now
focused uh on scaling kitty hawk and
just brought in a
a really amazing guy randall mays as my
as my partner
and scaling up the size of the fund and
hired an associate and all that kind of
good stuff so it's you know like
everything it's a journey and for me it
started very small with kitty hawk and
you know we're still a relatively small
fund but starting to get a little uh
a little traction and a little gravity
and build an interesting portfolio
the journey makes a lot of sense as you
described like even back
20 plus years ago you're getting the
first sort of taste
of as i like to say it's like
entrepreneurial combinatorics
in a sense all the different not only
aspects
to the entrepreneurial process on them
on a micro scale in terms of the
actual entrepreneur themselves and their
specific business and their specific
operational and strategic process for
their thing
but then there's the combinatorics of
all of the different entrepreneurs
themselves in all of the different
fields those fields and all of the
different strategies and operations
within those fields
so what you're doing is you're basically
tasting all the different flavors
of the rainbow and then what you get
is you get someone that really can work
on a strong scale not only with one on
one and helping
entrepreneurs actually succeed at what
they're striving to achieve but also
can help take funds from people in a
trusted way
and say i know that this is the right
thing because i can tell by the
entrepreneur by the passion by the
company by the strategy by their
operations by
their sales by by due diligence that you
know that that's
the proper place yeah i think that's
right on i mean it's a lot of
uh pattern recognition i would say
and like you know you see a bunch of
these you start to
develop some some commonalities or see
some commonalities there
and uh you're also able to to sometimes
really help accelerate the business
through leveraging your network bringing
the right capital partners together you
know opening up biz dev doors for some
of these companies
um you know the venture business is a
very strange business and that it takes
a really long time to know if you're
great at it or not
uh we're five we're six years into it so
far
and early i mean of our what's the thing
that
it's gonna be interesting to look back
and see whether or not this was a great
indicator or not but
usually you see a lot of failures with
with these companies we've been
very fortunate so far that we've only
lost two of our 25 portfolio companies
in
a little under six years now which is
really unusual and companies seem to be
ramping
and and you know well on their way and
so um
so that's just kind of interesting to
figure out you know are we finding the
right companies identifying the right
entrepreneurs the right technologies are
we providing value and helping
accelerate them
uh and it you know you just it's a lot a
lot of work it's an amazingly
privileged place to be to get to work
with these extraordinary
humans and to be able to you know add
what what you can to try to help them
along
um and you know i think i like you have
a real passion for learning i mean and
that's one of the things that's super
cool about venture capital right is
you're
constantly and if you look at you know
our focus areas it's ridiculous i had a
we're fundraising right now i had a
prospective lp who was like you guys
this is pretty
eccentric you guys got a lot of
different areas that you're uh
you're really interested in and yeah i
mean there's a lot of stuff on there but
you know we i love to learn about these
new things and
and the the technology the opportunity
areas are always shifting so
for me it's about a passion for learning
for identifying extraordinary human
beings to
to back and then finding great people
either in the singularity university
you know faculty network or abundance
360 network or just kind of a broader
network to help me go
really deep in these areas and try to
you know make sure i'm thinking about it
the right way
understand the technology the landscape
and then then make
hopefully good decisions but like at its
core it's about backing extraordinary
people and so to have a life where you
get to spend
time working with these people for me
has just been a ridiculous gift and
i love it
there's something so special about being
able to
see a pattern recognition happening of
different entrepreneurs and their north
stars and their
successes and their habits and sort of
identifying those on a power law and
then
going in and abstracting out that
pattern and then basically taking
that pattern of habits and and all the
different traits of success and then
helping other entrepreneurs that have
more stars but maybe don't have those
patterns of habits and characteristics
that they're doing
maybe they don't have that that style of
of discipline that's needed or that or
that
that harmonious sort of emotional
intelligence that's needed to build
relationships and get sales and that
type of stuff
that by sharing those wisdoms
and helping people with those patterns
it it succeeds at their goals
it accelerates our our trajectory
towards solving the
sdgs and all these other important
things that we really want to
yeah we want to hone in on teaching most
people
don't have mentors right and
most people i've found sometimes you
feel a little uncomfortable giving
feedback to people and helping
guide them like sometimes some some of
the things you want to share to help
them grow are not always the easiest
things to hear
but it's amazing the
the um the appreciation
that people have for getting feedback
you know not that that's all my
interaction with people but like
people want to do great you know they
want to be successful they
they want to have their company you know
touch as many people
as they can and people don't always know
you know frequently right we don't know
what the right answer is how to act
which is the first time we're dealing
with a problem
um and so being able to occasionally
help people you know kind of grow as
individuals as
as operators you know as entrepreneurs
uh
is super cool and i've just found in in
my life also like being able to have
um great people around me that i can
learn from and and grow from has made
you know a huge difference and i had to
kind of change
my thinking around that where yeah
there's some risk around okay
being transparent and letting people
know you don't know the answer or what
the right path is and sometimes
as an entrepreneur or business
professional you feel uh
incredible pressure to know to pretend
at least you know everything
and getting to a point of kind of
comfort and i think kindness towards
yourself
uh has been a huge evolution and kind of
freeing
element for me that's allowed me to to
thrive and accelerate kind of my own
growth and
and you know professional uh
opportunities as a result of that
yeah so getting people to feel
comfortable with that and knowing these
you know letting these entrepreneurs
know that you know we're all pulling
hard for you to work here you know be
successful here let us know you know
what can we do to help
help with that and sharing things that
we we
areas where we do know we can be helpful
yeah there seems to be a
cultural evolution happening in the
entrepreneurial space where it's
becoming
more spiritual in the sense of
being okay with being vulnerable being
okay with being transparent being okay
with
understanding that the quote
you can see the self in the other and
that
you can feel that unity style presence
and then then there's less of an ego
there's less
and then it becomes easier to share
these wisdoms across entrepreneurs and
should be people in general right we're
generally not us versus them it's we
right yeah that's the mindset yeah
exactly
yeah that's that's it and and it's it's
with the help of people like brene brown
and more and more of the vulnerability
but not to a fault at the same time
because there's also sort of the
there's a process that of like clicking
the rewind button
and like re-watching like traumatic
events or like replaying things that
don't serve you anymore that cause you
suffering
right there's these poles and extremes
that happen as well so to find that
middle path
buddha balance you know is uh is
critical
and that's also very true with the
entrepreneurial hustle and i'm sure that
that's also been one of the macro level
patterns is that sometimes if you're
you know if you're completely ignoring
some of the things that we were talking
about before we started that
like michael holt yesterday being on the
show was talking about well being that
if you're really not honed in on the
mindset
and working on the investigation of your
own awareness and becoming sovereign in
that sense
it's going to be difficult for you to
get the right balances on
the nutrition the sleep the
exercise the relationships intimacy
all these other aspects of life and so
you can tell with entrepreneurs because
a huge part of venture capital is
literally the soul of the entrepreneur
absolutely of everyone right and life is
is about mindset
i think more than anything your journey
through life i think is so driven by
you know the lens that which you see the
world and you see yourself
and um yeah it's just extraordinary i
mean that's been a bunch of the work
that
that i've done and i have this really
amazing
uh coach who has kind of helped me see
there's kind of a
almost like a decision tree of thinking
right where you start off at the
beginning like
okay you know some mornings you wake up
and you're kind of
i don't know you're a little down or
you're stressed out and
if that happens to me i'll think of to
myself like okay what you know did
anything change between yesterday and
today
no okay so it's just there's something
chemically or something going on
there's nothing really different and i
have a choice of how i'm going to
interpret
the world and like that's the branch
that i either i send my thinking in it
becomes a little self-reinforcing when
you realize
okay you have that initial thought
you're going to send it down a positive
path or a negative path
and when you start to realize that
you know we're living in just the most
extraordinary time we have
so you know access to just unbelievable
resources
knowledge capital education you know
health all these things are just
extraordinary in many many ways and you
start to shift in kind of that
abundant mindset and also kind of
part of it is is being kinder to oneself
i think
is really important not being i mean a
lot of things you said about
things that don't serve you well
starting to you know look forward and
look at all the incredible things and
gifts that you
do bring to the world and focus on the
positive and let go of the stuff that
doesn't serve you well
and just move forward you know yes yeah
and it
to also like we're here in la it's the
perfect place to really
hone in on the the
the way to describe it being like
unsubscribe from what doesn't serve you
and subscribe or follow
right what does interview and literally
just go and click
unfollow the accounts that literally
don't serve you
anymore that feed like primal instincts
and the ones that do serve you
spiritually intellectually emotionally
physically intimately you know follow
those subscribe to those holding
on the every input that we take in is
is massively critical to our fullest
actualized potential
100 agree i've been really fortunate to
get to work a lot with peter diamandis
and peter is so focused on mindset
and really um we do this program called
abundance 360
and we've been doing these workshops
with uh with attendees where we've been
kind of going through
mindset and scarcity mindset to abundant
mindset longevity exponential
uh mindsets and part of what he has
really talked a lot about we've tried to
share with the group is like
you know not spending time to your point
watching
the news listening to the news reading
the news all the time i mean you can get
we know that it's negative news that
cells that's how the human brain is is
wired to focus on those type of things
but if you look at the actual data this
is the most extraordinary time to be
alive it's the best time
ever in human history to be alive you
would never ever ever know that from
reading the news watching tv and you
know listening to these
folks talk and so acknowledge that spend
five minutes 10 minutes doing a quick
you know
dive into what's happening so you know
what's going on and then focus your
you know energy on learning and reading
and meditating and positive
stuff that's going to lift you up and
you know intellectually it's going to
lift you up from a spirit
and kind of i don't know just boost your
whole wellness
in in so many different ways and so i
i've been really interested in
thinking about the fact that news the
the news as it currently uh
is basically does not serve humanity
well right and it used to be that news
was like to have access to the public uh
networks there was a certain requirement
in terms of the quality of the broadcast
and there were very few of them and
and there just isn't that sort of
standard anymore and now we've got
something that is clearly
dividing us it's not serving us well
it's not moving humanity forward in a
positive way like many of the the social
networks and so
how do we think about you know an
evolution and getting to a point where
we're putting things in place and
focusing on technologies that are
actually
going to make us happier that's going to
serve us well that's going to
bring us together as opposed to separate
us because we are
so much more similar than we are
dissimilar but you
we don't focus on those things yeah
man there's so many good places to take
this okay i'm gonna take a little
s runway here first thing
is that on understanding
the truth of what is our biological
brotherhood and sisterhood now so we now
know thanks to
post 1953 that literally on a genetic
level
99.9 similarity right
and so that's sort of in a consciousness
perspective that would be like the
integral
that would be like we have the
integration
of the ocean the oceanic the symphonic
style of
oneness of unity that we all are
together and then the derivative or the
differentiation
is like the point one percent difference
between us
which is that unique north star that
unique contributory gift in the symphony
or playing the
the instrument or the melody that's
different from someone else's you have
your own unique solo in the symphony and
it's amazing and
and like now if we hold those two at the
same time that's what
we call self-realization realizing the
unity of all being in existence and
self-actualization which is actualizing
a unique goal
into the world your solo so there's that
and then there's also this sort of big
tree of possibility that exists
throughout your life and so you have
things like
we have these
these graphics that we use a lot in our
conversations
and this is the one from this is from
high level perception
chapter 2 seed theory and in this case
it's that you're looking at literally
the tree of possibility for every single
unique seed in the world the seed
just like the seed of the tree is just
like the seed of the human
in an analogy where the tree the tree
seed needs the basic
nutrients at its roots in order for it
to grow and flourish fruits
same thing's true with the human it
needs its basic needs met nutrients in
order for it to self-actualize
exactly and so you have this big tree of
possibilities that exist
and that at every single one of these
bifurcating moments that occurs like
you're describing along these
trajectories for entrepreneurs
it's so important for everybody that we
remember that there's always going to be
a choice that we can make that
is more towards well-being more towards
heaven and less towards suffering and
less towards hell more towards our
fullest solo potential in the symphony
and so then
i'm i'm really doing my best to sort of
leverage
these visual explanations you know that
earlier one that we were talking about
regarding
that sort of integration of all of the
individual neurons of the
collective mind of consciousness that
we're all experiencing but then that
unique differentiation
as well and then that last bit that i
thought was really interesting where we
started getting
was sort of that like ai coach vibe you
know you're talking about like what it's
like to
you know you have both your coaches that
help you and you coach other people
everyone sort of finds themselves
in that spot it's so beautiful and i
think in the future we're really going
to have these
ai coaches where i can on a more
frequent basis
be visualizing a
a a data visualization of not only like
my biometric stream which we're going to
talk about with longevity yeah
and so we want to eradicate pathologies
we want to retain
youthful homeostatic capacity throughout
our lives
but at the same time i want a a
visualization of that tree of
possibility where my ai coach is saying
hey alan i know that
you know that you're getting a an
inclination right now to maybe eat a
carb heavy meal
but if you choose to maybe eat uh
that that salad with some some apple on
top of it for
you know a little bit and only half of
it for now but then get back to your
focus sprint
you're actually going to achieve more of
your potential today than if you were to
eat that other right
and so just hang in there for another 30
minutes you're going to feel so much
better and yeah
you'll get over that you need the
ghrelin the ghrelin is the hormone that
is secreted for hunger and so ghrelin
usually comes in a peak
and then it stops so p it comes in for
maybe 30 minutes
and then it stops so that that way you
only feel your hunger for a small window
but then you're back on usually you drop
into ketosis and you're burning fat
i'm on keto right now for the last three
months and that has just been
fascinating to like one realize how
addicted i was to sugar
total tangent here but like it's just
mind-blowing like i've never been
addicted to a drug
and i it was like all i could think
about was wanting to
headed to venice to blue star donuts and
shove five donuts down my throat like
just
crazy but once you get through it yes
the sustain
energy the clarity of thought and to not
have that
uh that hunger that craving you're just
satiated most of the time
it's unbelievable it's been just like
totally freeing
and it's really cool amen yeah
that's badass and that's why we need
these styles
of we need some sort of accountability
this ai coach idea is like we have
accountability not only with our health
and we're analyzing our biometric stream
and are not for our longevity but we're
also achieving our north star goals more
effectively
all this type of stuff and we can do
this also in a way that leverages
what's known as homomorphic encryption
so that way
we can actually leverage the best
possible artificial
general intelligence algorithms and
analyses on our data
in a way that is it does not
even decrypt our data and it can perform
the computational analyses on it
which is fantastic yeah and that's kind
of that's the kind of stuff that
is emerging in cryptography and
mathematics which is fascinating
computer science
and so we have that to leverage as well
and so the reason why i'm kind of like
making this this runway with the several
like points that we've been illustrating
is that will's sort of macro level view
on the evolution of
entrepreneurship and the evolution of
what has been
now with you know being the executive
director with singularity university
and then doing kitty hawk ventures and
then
also a360 there's this sort of
process where people realize on their
trajectory that
okay what does it mean to self-realize
what does it mean to self-actualize
how do i ensure my my mindfulness my
health and my flourishing on a
moment-to-moment basis for me to
actually achieve these goals how do i
find these mentors how do i mentor
other people everyone sort of falls into
these patterns
that are so similar from all the
different guests we come on the show and
that's
that's one of the things that i think is
really interesting about you
and about this interview is that we're
both very synthetic in that sense
but your last couple of decades
especially have really honed in on
like a venture capital perspective and
also on a
on a community perspective
because i think people know this
probably by now but when
uh singularity university the
the idea of it is that
on a sort of metaphysical level is that
the exponential technologies that are
emerging right now
are totally sending us into a place of
like such accelerated
uh change that exactly that we're
heading
into some sort of like a singularity
point um
a metacortex a metaverse
place and these yeah so
singularity university has been uh is
very much about the
exponential acceleration of technology
less about the last piece and
you know ray has a passion for that but
just to be
to be clear we're not uh focused on
really on transhumanism and
and that piece there but uh there was a
real
some insights of ray kurzweil and peter
diamandis are the two founders of
singularity university and
ray had written this book called the
singularity is near which you know well
and is just an incredible
uh you know like four inch thick book of
uh
of uh difficult stuff to kind of digest
and get through but
um really really insightful and what
part of his insights were really that
more and more technologies were becoming
information technologies
information technologies grow at an
exponential rate
because they grow at an exponential rate
you can become very
predictive about where they're going to
go and
make all sorts of assumptions about when
certain products and services would be
feasible from a computation or
technology perspective
and because all these technologies were
getting ready to go through this
extraordinary change
you know and the world was going to go
through this extraordinary change and
individuals and businesses and
governments really had no idea this is
back now
12 13 years ago and you know no one was
talking about exponential growth and
people didn't understand
what that what that meant and the human
mind is not designed
to think that way we're designed for a
very kind of linear and local
world and um you know now everything
happens exponentially and globally
and so created su is this place where
people could come to to learn about what
was happening at the forefront of these
different technology areas and
to uh you know understand what was
happening with robotics and ai
and synthetic biology and quantum and
then also know
you know what does it mean when
something is growing exponentially and
people would come through these programs
and it would just blow their mind right
you'd get exposed to things that
and ways of thinking that you hadn't
ever been exposed to and then people
would go back to their
their companies and decide you know okay
i got to go out and be an entrepreneur
or how can i
singular is also a benefit corporation
and part of it is how do you use these
technologies
to solve the world's biggest problems
and um
so it's just been this incredible
community and an ecosystem now that's
developed i think almost
over 300 000 people uh at this point who
are part of the community and
think of like 180 chapters and almost
160 countries and
pre-covered we were on track to do like
20 large summits around the world so
but it's just this unbelievable global
community of people who are
you know passionate about technology and
how it can also be a force for good and
you and i were talking about this a
little bit before but
there's so much alignment now between
building great companies and leveraging
technology
and doing good you know moving the world
forward and you're seeing all these
instances now
of companies and investors who are so
focused on if our government's not gonna
make sure that we're doing this good
uh ultimately for the good of the world
uh and their bottom line companies and
investors have to focus on this stuff
now so i'm not an impact fund but i love
that that's the lens that i can
bring to looking at the companies that i
potentially invest in and
uh you know there's every there's just
such a huge wave
around this now yeah like
visually visually the way that
i see what we're talking about right now
is i see like uh
i see like uh
all of the i love that you're gonna draw
this right now yeah i can't wait to see
how this person
i see like a this whole
big like you know there's like you know
you said there's 300
000 people in the su community and then
there's you know this
big a360 community that exists and
there's
all these you know we have the kitty
hawk and we have all of the
extras and experts and we have all these
and then there's all these other you
know communities of epic people that are
also on planet around the planet
as well and then there's this sort of
like
everyone sort of has like their own
unique
like north star right vision
right everyone's got their little solo
that they're that they're undergoing
and then we have this sort of like
everyone's everyone's undergoing a
analysis
we're talking about patterns a lot of
patterns patterns patterns
so much of this is about patterns and
there's sort of this like
there's like this power law distribution
where you have like
a very
a very you know a tail end
right this is your the uh
this is like the maybe like five percent
of knowledge
that's going to give you you know
something like 95 of your results or
whatever
and this is why you have to you know
parse
for signal
over noise
and so everyone is going along these
everyone's going along these
these pursuits to their stars
and so my sort of my sort of like
perspective or take on this
is maybe something like as you see
the amount of people across the planet
that are
that are entrepreneurs in their
communities and you see this macro level
pattern of people
wanting to actualize some sort of a big
north star gift into the world
everyone's on these on these journeys
and pursuits playing their solos
but there's always this power law
pattern that occurs
where there's just these key principles
these key patterns these key habits of
genius
that are that enable people to access
they parse for that signal and they find
that that five percent of knowledge
that's going to give them 95
percent of the of the results and this
is the sort of
these are the styles of ways like
especially when you come on the show
i know that you've you've found this
in your own way like your own visual
representation
but i know it's something like this
because this is the pattern of genius
the genius finds the godhead the north
star and it reverse engineers it
and so whether it's on an individual
solo level or a collective
telic level at toward that god had like
singularities
near like ray kurzweil saying um so this
is why
like the visualization of it hopefully
for people
enables them to realize that okay the
whole thing that they're talking about
with
the quantified self movement and these
ai coaches and these mentorships and
these north stars and this data
visualization and
and the the kind of the future
architectures that maximize
people's abilities to make it less
molasses and more frictionless
on their path towards the right towards
their stars yeah i mean it's
uh we are our own you know largest
gating factor
right and it's just astounding to me i
mean people
um and i've been guilty of this for a
good chunk of my life uh you know can't
get out of my own way to realize my
my own potential and i learned
how to navigate life in a way that um
has opened up some of those
opportunities for me and allowed me to
kind of flow through life
a lot easier but it's just you know
we're all so much more capable
than we give ourselves credit for and so
i think
that is you know fundamentally for
people to internalize that
is critically important i think also
it's
impossible to know what anything truly
means at the moment it's happening
right and it just takes such there's
just no like we put these judgments on
all these things
it's almost always wrong like you just
don't know like kovid
could have been the worst thing that
that ever happened humanity or it very
well may be the best thing that's ever
happened to
humanity right it's just we won't know
that for a while
it's not to say it's not easy and
there's lots of you know horrible things
that have happened with it but
ultimately
it could create you know unbelievable
positive momentum in so many different
areas
our greatest traumas are almost always
our greatest treasures and it's hard to
detect that in the moment
exactly exactly and also i'm a believer
like
you know one little step in a certain
direction sends you down a path that
there's just no way to
to predict you know that you would have
ended up there i mean i wasn't positive
about joining
singularity university uh it was a
13-person organization at the time
yeah it was a big big risk but some of
the most extraordinary people coming
through the
the doors there and it aligned a lot
with a lot of my interests and so i
i took that risk and ultimately that
ended up being
probably the greatest professional
career move i've done and and also just
the most
satisfying in so many ways you know
intellectually and
um from a building a network and being
part of a community perspective as well
and so
so hard to predict this and so like
trying to just let go of that filter
of judgment and uh trying to walk
through life in a more kind of neutral
uh neutral to positive way i think just
you know opens up all sorts of
opportunities
and reminding yourself that the
plasticity of the human brain is
extraordinary and
you know you can teach old dogs new
tricks and you just gotta
to put in a little work and and you keep
growing and learning new
skills and and capabilities and talents
and insights
yes yes and to do it on a very
incremental level as well to re-pattern
a little bit of a habit
every single day um incrementally and
then
rather than the overwhelming like i
gotta change eight things tomorrow it's
like right you know just one tiny thing
like instead of waking up and rolling
over and grabbing your phone
just meditate consciously breathe right
or
even 30 seconds yeah that's wow just 30
yeah
just 30 seconds yeah if just tuning
inward and do that same thing at night
the next week as well and you've added
you know two things now
instead of you know being on the phone
at night right you're really tapping
into some potential right
yeah yeah wait to see what that starts
to do and what that leads to
and yeah exactly and then all of a
sudden you're you know you and your
your in your part your intimate partner
there that's
probably with you is like you're
noticing
that you know where is this piece coming
from right
right more peaceful human right i love
that
yeah yeah and then you're butterfly
effecting than that
out everywhere that you go and do
i want to ask as
you've identified that you're now
doing your own venture firm
kitty hawk that you're doing a360
that you're creating this these
you're in a sense you're creating
containers for people to
maximize their their potential whether
it be as a venture capitalist and
as a mentor to people or as somebody
that basically takes
groups of high-level entrepreneurs and
takes them to different
cutting-edge people in their industries
and helps them accelerate their goals
that you also know that there's the
criticality of the sustainable
development goals
that we have to meet the requirements
of living in an architecting those
protocols that enable us to live in the
hyper
abundant future like we want in
abundance 360 as we talk about
that optimism that the convergence of
technologies
but that we need those you know the
billion people that still want that
clean tap water on on axis or the
the you know not
literally being concerned about the
planetary hydrological cycle with
environmentally persistent
pharmaceutical pollutants eppps or that
the parts per million of co2 you know
these
these types of things that still
that we're still trying to you know
figure out the proper solutions to and
kitty hawks doing its best to kind of
fund
to make sure that we're sus
reaching those sustainable development
goals and a360 is
doing its best to sort of make sure that
that the entrepreneurs themselves are
realizing that we need to
make those protocols is that something
that you're
constantly you know ebbing into the
practices
those long-term futures it's basically
all about those long-term
futures and the ethics and morals around
that as a planet
yeah i think uh yes is the is the answer
i mean we're not
an actual impact fund but we're
very focused on positive impact you know
how do we find
amazing certainly there's a do no harm
like we will never invest in anything
that we think
you know might potentially create uh
harm to the planet or to people
um and i think uh now more than ever
it's easy to build
incredible businesses around that are
are in alignment with
taking care of humans and taking care of
our planet um
you know it just astounds me that people
focus on
the coal industry and you know we have
an obligation to help people
through job training to build new skills
to be part of new emerging industries
but you think about the economic
opportunity
around creating a green sustainable
energy infrastructure and transitioning
the world to that
it's probably the single greatest
economic opportunity
that's ever existed and it's
you know what could be more critically
important than you know turning
uh turning us off away from the course
that we're we're currently on um
so we're very focused in trying to make
sure we're helping kind of be i love uh
this is a
tagline that obvious ventures um has
which is world
positive that i just love and yeah this
just notion of like how
do we move the world forward in a
positive way through
the companies that we're investing in
and supporting
how do you know the
level of consciousness the level of
awareness
of the people that are coming into the
spheres that you're
making the containers for like do you
and when you're doing
kitty hawk are you looking at when
you're looking at that like soul
fusion of the entrepreneur like and then
when the people are coming into the a360
community do you
do you have some sort of a way for you
to kind of like gauge their level
of ethics and morals and spirituality
and
and understanding of world positive
architecting
yeah i think so that's part of the
diligence process
of of every company right is getting to
spend time with the team with
the founder founders and try to
understand who they are as human beings
um how they think about the world what
drives them
you know what their goals are and
aspirations and that to me is in
many ways the most important part of the
whole
effort right because it's like business
cycles are going to change
there's always going to be you know
unexpected
problems it's really really hard to
create great businesses and
you know you just never know what's
coming down the pike in the world and so
finding people who are
uh care about other people who are gonna
work their their butts off to try to
make something happen
but care about culture or in this for
the right reasons you know they have a
mission and a passion about creating
something it's not just about
god i need to be a unicorn like i don't
want to be part of
those type of businesses i mean it's
great if there's a mission like i need
to go out and
i want to make sure that i can cure
depression we have a company called
inner cosmos that's
brain computer interface company and
they're focused on
uh how do you solve how do you cure
people or help people who have the most
severe treatment resistance form of
depression
i think that could you know incredible
amounts of money are spent
on treating people with depression you
know we know it
it affects so many people and has been
increasing throughout the world so it's
a huge problem
huge market opportunity they're focused
on solving that
the end result will be that it should be
an enormous business over time
but that's different than someone who's
like okay i need to build a
i want to make a billion dollars i gotta
oh someone told me depression was an
issue i had a friend who was depressed
and
and that leads them as opposed to a real
passion around what they're doing so
that's
critically important it's um you know
when you're doing
group events you don't always know kind
of the level that people are at and so
part of it
is providing opportunities to kind of
bring people
who are interested uh and who maybe need
some of this kind of
up to uh the next level to explo expose
them
to some of these we do lots of workshops
around uh a360 and helping people
you know a lot we've been focused a lot
around mindset
and doing these different uh yeah
exercises and that enable people to kind
of
think differently and you and i were
talking a little bit about this like we
did one around longevity
i was part of this longevity learning
trip and as part of it
um with peter we did this exercise
around you know how long do you think
you're gonna live to be
and uh and for me it was just such a
fascinating you know you hear people
talking about
i'm going to live to 150 or 500 and
after spending a week kind of getting
exposed to a bunch of these
leading institutes and george church and
david sinclair and these entrepreneurs
and stuff people who are just doing
incredible things on longevity front
by the end of that i was like okay there
is a really high probability that i will
live to at least 120
and i'd been kind of an 80 or 90 year
old person in my mind and then all of a
sudden you know okay so i just got
30 or 40 more years like whoa
like where am i in my life span and what
does that mean what else you know you
just start to
think really differently about making
sure you're taking care of your body and
taking care of your mind and
all the great things we're going to be
able to accomplish and and working hard
to make those things happen and so
um that's one of the things i love about
this work is being able to help people
have these insights and kind of grow as
as humans and then that hopefully
translates into some nice
business things as well
are there
workshops where the
it seems like the workshops that you're
describing are very
self-actualization oriented which is
fantastic
are there also workshops where it's
maybe self-realization oriented where
it's an investigation of one's own
awareness
yeah i think that's part of it for sure
i mean a lot of times we're trying to
get a sense of where
people are and and pushing them to to
think about
where they are we've got a lot of
members of strategic coach who are part
of
the program and they do quite a bit of
that and kind of focusing you
in on thinking about you know where you
are your assumptions about all sorts of
different things and we brought some of
that into
abundance 360 as well so i think that's
a part of
you have to do an honest assessment of
where you are
to i think to be able to figure out kind
of what you need to focus on and where
you want to go
yes and also something along the lines
of a question
proposed to them along the lines of well
how much do you think does
consciousness play in the nature of
reality
yeah we have not posed that that
specific one
i have no doubt you would like to lead
that and introduce that one yeah
yeah and yeah and one and i would say
that the one of the key reasons
why is because like you indicated a
moment ago is that
as people undergo these processes what
occurs is that
naturally as we've been explaining
there's a butterfly effect that happens
with everything that they do
afterwards right so they begin seeing
that self in the other they begin seeing
that they begin experiencing everything
as
one big orchestra play symphony that's
occurring
we all come from that same source that
same big bang that we
propose we come with every 20
000 breaths that we take come from the
photosynthesis of phytoplankton and
trees that's per day
that we take those breaths and so you
begin wondering like i'm interdependent
on that and that then that
everything that i do has an
interdependent butterfly effect that's
happening
right and so all of it's all a big
feedback system with our state of
awareness
and then whether it's self-actualization
or self-realization and then
that just existence like physical
existence right it's were one
tiny interconnected planet floating
through the
the universe and you know that the
people
haven't many people haven't quite
realized kind of the dependencies like
we
are dependent on those trees right we're
dependent on clear water yet we've had
this mindset
of that we are distinct and separate
from
the natural world and that's where we've
gotten ourselves into so many
uh issues so many problems and i think
now we're starting
we're definitely starting to head in the
direction it's not universal yet but
it's clear that there's momentum heading
in the direction of
everything has to be done in harmony
with nature for this really to be
a sustainable existence and to kind of
realize the
i mean how amazing if we had clean
energy clean water clean
air you know all these things to help
people really
live the best possible healthiest most
actualized lives
that they could i mean that's kind of
the wrong ingredients to to functioning
right you got to have all these
yeah and we had the indigenous wisdoms
that have been passed down for millennia
that
are thinking in like a seventh
generation principle around everything
that they do and modernity the economic
machinery
being so ignorant of
the interdependent relationship and so
that's why we're upgrading to that
capitalism 2.0 that is next level
abundant protocols and infrastructures
that leverage decentralization and
tokenomics and all these other aspects
that take into account in every decision
that we do
a seventh generation principle so it's a
synthesis of indigeneity and modernity
into something that transcends
both of them but includes them at the
same time yeah i love that in this
movement away from kind of the
the quarterly focus for businesses right
it's like it's not just about
your share price anymore it really is
about your your impact
on society as a whole and starting to
think uh
beyond the the the quarterly kind of
earnings report i mean we're clearly
not there yet and there's a lot of bs
that's you know a lot of people just
kind of
talk in the talk but not walking the
walk and but
that's it's going to have to happen if
we're going to ultimately
you know turn this this big tanker in a
different direction and thrive i think
yes because as soon as you do at a
company level make a decision like
instead of that quarterly
focus on stock price what we're going to
do is we're going to
we're going to take a mission driven
investigation into what our true purpose
is and
as eric weinstein talks about so much is
the
embedded growth obligation of the
companies to just
grow grow grow grow grow how does it
grow grow grow
it's like well okay but what's the
purpose what's the mission what are we
here to do
and then in doing that process what
happens is
you by slowing down and doing that inner
engineering that reflective process what
happens is you end up attracting
the millennial gen z and generation
alpha talent
that is going to be your main problem
solvers of your future
you're struggling right now to attract
that talent because you don't have a
mission and a purpose that's divine and
that's transcendent and that's
a noble aim uh and so that's exactly
what if any of these big giants want to
actually pivot
all most of the young people companies
that are started by millennials in gen z
they're only mission purpose driven like
what
what's uh what's coca-cola's mission
right what is it
like do you think open happiness you
know 40 40 grams of
refined sugar right yeah right like i'm
trying to figure
you know and all the downstream effects
of what the
healthcare industrial complex is now
taking on its back from
the uh those health downstream effects
so
it's the awakening process has a
feedback
mechanism where you become
more of as
this perennial spiritual traditions
would say across the planet that you
become basically a channel for
god consciousness or christ
consciousness buddha consciousness lao
tzu confucius level consciousness
everything you do your family your
friends your children
the community your work your
entrepreneurship your north star
everything becomes affected by your
highest level of morality spirituality
ethics and everything that you touch and
but we need the
science angle behind it as well in terms
of
actually understanding we didn't
understand before we kind of we knew the
interdependence but we didn't know it at
the level of well the photosynthesis
from the phytoplankton is providing us
with 70
of the oxygen that we inhale 20 000
times a day
like we need to really realize that
that sacred divine interdependent
relationship
on a scientific level and that's when
things become more and more like okay
well i see it from a science angle and a
spiritual angle now
and so because of that i can
not be in a silo of physicalism or
not be in a silo of spirituality which
is where
so many people find themselves as siloed
right in those things right
and we want to de-silo we want to
synthesize yeah and that's answering to
see some of those worlds come
together sometimes and uh
you know i've been on some calls where
some of the very
science-focused people are really
aggressively attacking the
head and the sand spiritual people and
pushing them
to really you know think a little bit
more and
and um i think you're the the bigger
point is
this melding of the two i think is so
is so critical and and the right path i
mean we've got to get back to
a world where it is about science and it
is about
clear facts and and so you can make the
right decisions
um you know ultimately that's what's got
to win the day but also doing it
uh in a way and thinking about the the
world we're creating and
and mental health and and helping people
actualize and
and because we do have this
extraordinary opportunity right now
to to to create you know i hate to use
the word utopia
because there always will be i'm sure
prototyping
protocols i haven't heard that what is
that protopia because so many people
tell me the same thing there they go
they go you're just a utopian and i'm
like no it's a protopia which is just
incremental bettering
that's all it is oh i love that yeah so
100 agree with that
yeah we're heading in that path and we
need to just keep on it and kind of lose
this
fear-based scarcity yes mindset and also
you know there's just i think the
growing inequality we were both talking
before this about
some of the uh articles that ray dalio
has been publishing talking about kind
of the arc of
of empires and where the u.s kind of
falls and
it's a downwards in a downward
trajectory right now that does not
end particularly well unless we start to
make some some real
changes and you've got this emerging
china that's you know displaying all the
the signs of of uh of you know that they
will be the
the dominant world power and um anyway
so there's a lot of things that really
need to change and evolve and and the
great news is we have the resources
we have you know the intelligence and we
have the
the passion i think that people the
drive to go do these things we need some
of the political will now to kind of
make these things happen
yeah yeah and in the political will and
the entrepreneurial
talent and focus we because of the
distractive culture
it's difficult to to take thousands of
people that
are all behind the groove of this really
beautiful song
like we have with maybe tesla as an
example like can we
take the the architects of the those
decentralized protocols that we're
talking about that inclusively stakehold
like physicians and their patients
so there's no perverse incentives when
the physician gets paid by the
pharmaceutical company like purdue
pharma to prescribe something like
an opioid rather than if the physician
was actually also
trained a it had an inclusive stake in
the physicians life outcome
a that and b was also trained in the
eastern
traditions as well as the western ones
so that they could
hone in on the nutrition and all these
other aspects to the health care
right it's wellness right and there's
alignment around improving wellness
and health outcomes and you're starting
to see some of that you know it's
certainly have i've got a company called
vitalize health that's focused on
medicare patients so you know the where
most of the
health care dollars are actually spent
and trying to figure out how to deliver
these there's the government's created
these accountable care organizations
where
it's just what you said you're you take
on responsibility as a
as a physician and as a provider to help
kind of provide
better care to make the right decisions
for these people to improve their health
outcomes and share in the savings as a
result of that
and that's an example of just a great
alignment right
and there's just so many opportunities
about uh to
to align businesses that way so the
outcome is
is world positive yeah and it takes that
time
of that focused energy of thousands of
architects to do that process on a daily
basis and to not be
distracted because that's why in the in
the radio illustration
the the only reason why it looks that
way for the us
is because the us is extremely
distracted from
the the the repetitive
the fiat currencies we didn't need to go
we did need to go through 2008 but
i'm just saying that we could have
it's it's it's very ironic i don't know
if you you've seen it but like the
descent and ascent happen at the same
time like where
the lehman brothers collapsed and then a
month later satoshi nakamoto published a
bitcoin white paper right
and like these things had they happened
at the same time the
the ascendant descent and so but
we can take the wake-up call when it's
coming to us
you know knock knock knock we can take
the wake-up call we can run with it now
in 2020 2021 2022
and architect what we're talking about
or we can kind of continue that
sort of lethargic apathetic
you know mindset of the downslope and
then we
we don't have to rock it back up as fast
we can rock it back up as fast as super
possible
to have that more abundant not only
mindset but also
actually the protocols so it's two part
what i've seen
it's both in the mindset of the
individual which is
this is funny because it's the exact
conservative liberal in the united
states
it's that it's the mindset of the
individual the that
north star achievement picking yourself
up and going at
but it's also on that liberal side it's
the social fabric
needs to be more conducive for meeting
those basic needs of the seeds and
also for the eradication of the perverse
incentives that exist so that it can
actually be the next gen
protocols that make it easier for
individuals to to rise up to their
to those challenges that's that's the
synthesis of the left and right in the
in the us from what i've been able to
analyze
and understand and so we can actually
the us
can can can recover from what appears to
be that down
and head back up to become a powerful
force to reckon within the world but it
is going to require us to take a look at
places like china
and to say well what are because right
now it's
super bad actually this is the reason
why you know your
current partner plus you know my
fascination with the diplomacy between
usa and china
i would say that the
memes that exist currently in the social
fabric of the us is to fear and hate
china
and it sucks and i know that a lot of uh
china's propaganda
also has somewhat similar intentions
about the united states
but there's nothing more powerful than
actually going there and you know
becoming friends with people there and
like with you with your
romantic partner as well you guys you
get
a new level of knowledge and
appreciation and intertwining and
diplomacy which has been
talked about for thousands of years if
you want to make it so that two tribes
get together you
marry people from the tribes and then
there is no then there's an inclusive
stakeholding so there's no ins that you
can't actually have the incentive to
kill each other
right and so you have to we have to
really look at china and
honestly have a conversation about some
of the things that they're doing that
are actually better
for they're extraordinary in society and
then we synthesize
kind of like again the western
individualism
with sort of that more eastern maybe
collective china-india-style
mentality into one more unified i think
there's about i mean there's you know
lots of
uh places to find fault with china for
sure
there's lots of extraordinary elements
about it my wife is born and raised in
china
um and i've had a chance to to go there
quite a bit
and it's just extraordinary to see how
that country
operates and um the fact that you have
one individual
who stays in power if they do a decent
job
for for the uh the the populous
and that one individual makes decisions
that gets a whole country moving
really quickly in different directions i
mean i've had times where
i've gone there and you know all the
scooters on the road are gas powered and
polluting and i'll come back
nine months later and every single
scooter is electric or they just went
all electric and their buses i think in
beijing or shanghai and you know they
make a decision it's the right thing to
do
and they do it you know they've decided
that the environment is one of their top
five five-year goals and so all their
energy goes into
okay we're going to transition to be a
green sustainable energy country
we need to be doing that stuff you know
they're making huge investments in
in ai and in quantum and things that are
have some risk to us as a country if we
don't
continue to you know invest or if we
don't increase the investment that we're
we're doing
we tend to get really sidetracked i
think in the us here
on some of these individual liberty
issues and i'm all america you know it's
incredible the freedoms and liberties
that we have i think there's things that
are not serving us
well that have become you know these
political hotbeds that you can't even
can't touch gun gun control i mean
there's just no question if you look at
the
the data right that guns are a terrible
thing for
for the u.s and the number of people who
are getting killed or severely injured
and
as opposed to the number of times
someone actually uses a gun to
protect themselves or their family i
mean it's just it's not worth the
societal risk and benefit or people use
it on themselves or a loved one is the
is the data but we can't seem to get
beyond that
um and so there's things like that where
i feel like we have swung
so far towards an individual rights kind
of it's all about the
the person and me and my right to be
able to do whatever i want and not wear
a mask when
the data all shows like these are
terrible things for
our society and is causing a huge burden
on our society
economically you know deaths like all
these sorts of things and and we can't
seem to
get beyond that i'm not sure how we
start to
to change that way of thinking i i am
pre-code i was supposed to have this
opportunity to go to
uh israel general stan mccrystal and
howard schultz that
would put together a small group of like
12 people were going to go to israel and
we were going to learn
about their service efforts there and so
in israel people
spend a couple years in the military or
in other groups serving the country
and general mcchrystal wants to bring
that concept
to the u.s so an opportunity for people
to to give
to for them to be able to connect with
other people throughout this country to
see things that they don't normally get
to see i mean
people are in their you know their
little bubbles here and
one of the things that i've realized is
you know we're all
we're all the same basically you know
there's it's just one planet of
people we should be viewing ourselves as
one people and one
not all the nation state no longer is
necessary or serves us well
and so anything we can do to help
encourage people to
be able to connect with other people to
be able to empathize with them
i think serves us so well and gives
people such a broader kind of
viewpoint uh for thinking about the
world and their own place in it and
and trying to get away from that kind of
me versus them
type of mindset that we often fall into
right someone
uh we don't know them so they're scary
or they're a threat to us and
they're just human beings who are
dealing with their own [ __ ] just like
everyone else you know
and uh and to be able to understand that
and bring that ability to connect and
kindness i think is
is super super important
at a level of consciousness development
and awakening
the more awake you become
the more you experience what are called
transpersonal or non-dual states of
awareness the more that you get to those
levels what happens is
everything else that we're talking about
xenophobia bigotry guns
none of those things even come anywhere
near your essence
because all you're doing is just
constantly in a state
of what is the absolute highest morals
and ethics and spirituality
joy peace bliss
kindness compassion empathy yeah
butterfly affecting that out everywhere
you go and that's not to bring it all
the way to the fault where that you
completely ignore the the the needs of
the physical because you you still again
it's with that synthesis
of the physical so you do retain that as
well
but that there's
all these issues that modernity faces
xenophobia bigotry all these types of
stuff
it's really solved from elevating one's
own awareness
consciousness to these baselining to
higher higher levels
re-baseline keep going keep going it's
like the paradox
is that we're perfect already
but that we're also always a work in
progress
and that's one of the most beautiful
enigmas
of realities is that exact
thing and so i want to ask
and i know there's still like i just
want to tell people before i ask this
question that the amount of fields
is ridiculous and you saw it in that in
that graphic
earlier that we were that we were
sharing
on the stream but that
like this is i think one of the top ways
to become
polymathic and that
and there's you know food computing
fintech longevity cyber security network
sensor space advanced materials med tech
mobility synthetic biology aiml
robotics and this is from a very you
know polymathic
scientific business oriented perspective
engineering perspective which is
excellent
and then like the synthesis of this with
also the spirituality the morality the
ethics the dialectic that occurs for
people to understand that
at the same time right that that
ultimately leads to
like this is that massive polymothy i
love that
and then to have that which
so much of science and modernity and
engineering just
breezes past or completely ignores and
then it wonders
why does our economic machinery treat
people like cogs
and why do we have so many of the mental
health issues well
that if people have experiences of what
perennial spiritual mystic traditions
have been teaching for thousands of
years
then we don't have those same issues and
i would say it's extremely important to
embed
that in non-dogmatically
non-fundamentally as again as a
perennial
spiritual wisdoms uh in from a very
scientific angle like we were saying
earlier
at in all of these venture funds in all
of these
communities in all of the fortune 500
ceos in all of the davos's and world
economic forums and un general
assemblies and
congresses of the planet all the
billionaires and high net worth people
to really have a biometric analysis like
is this person living in an egoic state
of consciousness
because if they are and they're running
a fortune 500 company we probably
that's probably one of our main maladies
of civilization
is that yeah there's so many hurt
people out there right hurt people hurt
other people and it just creates this
this cycle uh unfortunately where you
continue to
to you know propagate pain and and
suffering and
um i don't want to really get political
but you know i
uh in some ways i feel bad for our
president
right now like he's clearly someone who
is a
hurt individual and had a i think a very
abusive and unhealthy
upbringing and i absolutely detest his
policies and how he
handles himself and uh what he stands
for but
that's the result unfortunately of hurt
people
hurting him and kind of continuing that
on you think about the impact
he's had and the amount of pain and
suffering that he's created as a as a
result of that
you know it's heartbreaking and so part
of what needs to happen and is happening
right now some of the work that's being
done around mdma
and psilocybin and these late stage
clinical trials
is just extraordinary and their ability
to
to help heal people and to get them to a
point where that cycle
is broken and they can approach the
world in a really really different way
and
you know the efficacy of these things
it's just it's mind-blowing uh
to see that you know the the impact that
it can have
in such a short period of time on
individuals
uh is just you know people have suffered
their whole life with things that in a
matter of you know one or two or three
treatments in a very short period of
time can let these
these traumas go and this pain go and
we've all suffered traumas in
in different ways no matter you know
what type of life you've been through
right there's things that have
impacted you uh negatively and that
might be
still kind of holding you back and now
to have the opportunity for
something that is non-addictive that is
incredibly efficacious that is
incredibly
safe that you can use and that we can
help
these people get healthy and get get
healed
and be able to focus on other things and
give back to the world and approach the
world in a really different way
super super exciting time
i'm happy that you brought it up because
it was a topic that we both wanted to
talk about
and you're totally right you know thank
goodness for
rick doblin and maps multi-disciplinary
association for psychedelic studies
thank goodness for
you know even getting you know
breakthrough recognition through the fda
thank goodness for the you know us
government um
thank goodness that that the
acknowledgement of these
sort of consciousness elevating
substances that are purposely secreted
across the planet for this exact
use are finally being leveraged
uh and they have been for a really long
time for thousands of years but
the
there are there are other reasons why
they were
made uh illegal and that
those will become also potentially more
transparent and clear those
reasons over time but that uh getting
the most powerful people in the world
to undergo these processes of awakening
inevitably leads to the downstream
actualization of more and more people
like you said her people hurt other
people
and uh healed people heal other people
yeah yeah it allows people to bring
their their best selves right to
everything they do
and uh to be able to i think show
kindness and connect and
and you know it just enables you to
to empathize right with people in a in a
different way
um it's so so powerful and it's a we're
at a point in human history where we
desperately need this innovation to
happen and so to start to see these
things becoming
mainstream right on the cusp of becoming
mainstream and
being readily available to more and more
people i think is super super exciting
and i believe is going to have just a
profound
impact on the us and and on the world
and kind of kind of helping us evolve to
uh a next way of of being
yes no that's my hope anyway me too me
too
me too i know i know
now let's let's play uh with one of the
points that we had while we were talking
uh throughout our convo
what do you think is the purpose of
reality why does reality exist
jesus um
why does reality exist
i don't i mean i think first of all i
think we see
i'm not sure that i know how to answer
that question exactly um
i think uh we see
reality is so subjective we see such a
narrow piece of what is happening so
you know our reality is a tiny little
slice of what's actually
happening um i mean i think the huma i
like i know one of the topics that you
love to get into in the name of your
uh podcast you know simulation um
both ray uh kurzweil and peter diamandis
believe
that we are living in a simulation i'm
not sure that i necessarily
am there yet but i also find
uh the human body to just be
just mind-blowing like how is it
possible
um and you know the world that we've
been able to create the things we've
been able
uh to figure out but really just like
the human body to me
how how we operate and the complexity
uh it's just so extraordinary
um and so anyway that's a that's a bit
of a tangent but
i find that just really miraculous and
you know i i don't know i'd be
interested to hear how you answer that
question no one's ever
uh asked me that before and i think i
haven't clearly formulated a great
answer other than i believe we see such
a narrow
piece of it what it serves that's
actually a key that was actually
a massive key because it triggered
something
interesting which was that the same way
that
we only see the
the 700 to 400 nanometer-ish on the
electromagnetic spectrum in terms of
visual uh
it's fascinating because that similar
analogy can be drawn to
our universe out of the multiverses
right
that was an interesting one that sparked
from right from that the parallel
parallel realities that are all taking
place you know at the same time and
what's going on with quantum
and the entanglement i mean it's like
there's a lot of stuff that is
like pretty mind-expanding you know as
you try to put your uh your arms around
it may i may i
also um please uh
the nomenclature of simulation is
a is something that makes
there's like so many different i guess
ways to interpret the hermeneutics of
what simulation means
to use a spiritual word to describe what
a modern enter to
describe an interpretation of a modern
idea
but the thing is is that
what would
if we reverse engineer a godhead
right in this case the godhead we have
to make a hypothesis about the godhead
as what like what the point of reality
is right and then the hypothesis might
be something like i've been using three
words to try and describe it which is
consciousness
exploring infinity so that
there's an infinite amount of states of
phenomenology and
qualia and experience that exist
and that consciousness is just eternally
undergoing the explorative process
and it's doing it cyclically which is
why like sir roger penrose
who won the nobel prize in physics in
2020 believes in cyclic cosmology
not in the sense that we come back to
this exact same reality that's boring
we're never coming back to this exact
same reality but that we've been
exploring reality designs and different
vehicles to put ourselves into this is
four limbs
two eyes carbon-based dna encoded but
you have to be like walt disney and
imagine
all these other different soul vehicles
and realities that exist
and then what you can do is you can
begin thinking like okay well
maybe it makes sense when i hear the
words you know singularity is near when
i hear
what uh when i experience vr
ar mixed realities when i see the
bio and neurotech additions that are
being made to
to people when i see artificial general
intelligence being developed like
maybe it is that the synthesis of those
things
is called the metaverse and that just
like
we are going to slowly be in in
immersing ourselves more and more in
indistinguishable
virtual worlds that maybe this already
is one of those that we
came from that and we're going back into
it
and it's cyclical in the sense that the
godhead is the metaverse
and that we're going to immerse
ourselves in more of these infinite
explorations of realities
and our consciousness and our energy
will be you know
transition and be rebirthed and yeah
that that makes sense to me actually
um you know i don't know that i
necessarily believe
uh in god
like is this a part of a master
orchestration or is this um
you know biol compounds chemicals
nutrients coming together and evolution
going on this fantastical
journey i do believe though that i do
believe in consciousness
and that the consciousness continues on
which then causes you
to think about okay what is that this
idea of a metaverse and what do you
do transition into something else or um
you know what is that that kind of after
this piece is gone you know what is the
what is the next iteration i don't you
know it's still evolving in my head
uh what that is but but the scenario you
paint um
makes sense to me and kind of resonates
and then another question to ask then
would be something like
will you be a both a
designer and a player in those games
that we're talking about the continued
exploration
and is the answer hard to know but i
would hope so you would hope so so yeah
i would love i would hope so and so then
my
my next sort of point then would be that
if all eight billion people are
undergoing both being the designers and
the players in those games
then we are the designers and players of
this
right and so then when when people say
the word
god we are that we
are this this is all that right
and that's what the perennial spiritual
traditions have been saying the mystic
traditions
over 5 000 years from ancient egypt and
mesopotamia all the way up until
and in this valley with the vedic rishis
all of them have been saying and through
zoroaster and the axial age and the
explosion of all the ones that exist
today
that that common perennial spirituality
is that my awareness
my consciousness my beingness my is-ness
my existence
is god and that it's eternal it's
infinite it's cyclic it's exploring
and that that is it and that now we take
science and
we simulation theory and we just
leverage sort of the technological
protocols that enable us to go into the
next
immersion that's a hypothesis
so how do you think technology then
does does technology have a role in that
technology isn't really needed
right i guess for you to try for you to
transcend and for this
evolution to to continue for you to go
into kind of your next
uh existence technology i guess changes
the game
changes the experience at least in in
this
universe well
how would the question would be how
would
uh humans on the planet uh
if meditating on mountaintops and not
building
artificial general intelligence how
would they undergo the metaverse
recursion would be a question to ask
well is it not just a natural
is it a natural big bang and big crunch
that's that's
and if it is the death rebirth if it is
cycle
yes it may be both in a sense
that it's uh are you saying actually
that it's technology that enables you to
do that it's the evolution of technology
that ultimately will allow us to
oh interesting okay i took it to be
that it was just consciousness you know
the energy
of our existence that's why i was going
to say it's both in that sense because
the energy of the existence is what
enables the process
as we build the technological
infrastructure right then
enables us to go through the whole cycle
into a different explorative
interest so maybe back to this existence
or a rebirth here but more likely you
think
a rebirth someplace else something along
the lines of like
we're so like imagine like that whole
electromagnetic spectrum visuals that
you brought up earlier i think that's
that's so spot on regarding
our imagination and creativity being
just just
quelled to such a small tiny degree
there's so much potential that exists
for universes uh and
conscious agents in those universes
because i mean
just go look at the catalog of video
games that exists right now there's so
many different
creative universe designs that people
are making but one of the things that
seems to be
a property that we talked to david
johnson dj about on the show who's a
simulation designer in virtual worlds
just yesterday on the show that one of
the things that seems to be most common
is this
three space using x y and z
in this three space format because it
sort of
comes from some sort of an origin zero
point and then has these three
axes yeah axes which then enable
the sort of space phenomenon
to occur yeah interesting and so that
might be a
more common property of the universes
that we design
and then time seems to be one that is uh
you know this is one thing that many
people can't handle simultaneity
you can both simultaneously see the good
in the us and in china you can
simultaneously see the good in indian
and modernity in the left and the right
and conservatives and liberals in the us
in this case it would be can you
literally
hold the fact that you are both
eternal infinite biologically at the
same time as you can hold
finite biological time where you
literally have a north star and that
you're in
like fun pursuit and like i think the
answer that is yes yes
i'm not there yet but i definitely know
some
people who really are there and believe
that
you know in their core and it's amazing
to see and they work very hard in this
life
in this existence to optimize it and be
the best that they can do but also have
kind of a much longer game and broader
perspective
uh which is really beautiful and freeing
and energizing in in many ways
yes yes yes i love that and i hope i
hope that
one of the things that can come from our
dance
is that
if i can come and help
some of what both the
founders of the kitty hawk companies are
doing and
some of the a360 community as well
if i can come and help be of service to
what topics we've been talking about to
help
people become
more ethical moral spiritual
philosophical
artistic as they do their science their
engineering
um and their actualization of their
business entrepreneurial goals into the
world
that that is like definitely one of my
main like loves and passions and roles
and i would love to feature more of them
i love that i very much appreciate that
would love to love to figure out how we
can integrate that more into into what
we're doing
hell yeah hell yeah well i love it what
a what an
epic program but i knew it was gonna
roll in such a like flowerful
way and it's such a joy to be able to to
talk to you and like you know you don't
get a chance to kind of i don't know
intellectually think about some of these
things and talk about some of these
things so fun to get to
go down memory lane and and get to you
know explore some of the possibilities
of uh
of the world and life together so i
appreciate being uh being able to join
you today
yeah you're awesome i love you i love
that thanks man i appreciate that
and thanks for the great work you're
doing i mean amazing amazing content
that you're
putting out there and uh and you know i
love kind of the
the mix of uh technology and
spirituality
and all these things kind of coming
together in a really you know
intellectually interesting way and and
kind of human
and heart centric way as well uh which
is you know
i think what we need it's the
intersection of uh of those two things
that the world needs kind of going
forward
you are seeing me you're seeing it
you're registering it and it feels
really good
i love it love it i love it i love it
and with much more to also unpack on
all this round two and beyond there's
tons more to create
hell yeah thanks everybody for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts on the comments below
on all things frontier technology and
all things spirituality as well as we
were talking about
we'd love to hear your thoughts share
the episode
with more people that need to hear
sort of this pattern of how to actualize
gifts into the world and how to see this
entrepreneurial flourishing that's
occurring
especially at the frontiers of
technologies help share it with people
like the video subscribe also check out
the links in the bio below
all of them are there also all of will's
social accounts are there go give them a
follow linkedin instagram twitter also
the kitty hawk website the oc.vc as well
as a360.com
the abundance 360 community as well as
su.org for singularity university check
out those links
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the spiritual leaders the scientists the
engineers in your communities around the
world that you believe in
support them help them grow you can
support simulation the links are below
to our show
help us flourish as well achieve all our
big goals
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
we love you very much thank you for
tuning in awesome thank you alan
thanks everybody thank you we'll see you
soon